soit
une autre illusion dans la braderie des
porte-parole des journées de la culture
cette année oui hibou questions de
diversité à l'écran et journées de la
culture aussi montrent que l'adversaire
de plus en présente sur nos scènes un
peu partout au québec
c'est un des pionniers avaient conçu
avec boule noire avec rigueur comment
voyez sauf dôme est immensément fier moi
je suis très fier parce qu'avant c'est
un noir qui rentrait dans une pièce tu
disais pas c'est le tome 2 la haute où
il joue quelqu'un qui jouait à l'école
comme ça tue des noirs qui est rentré
dans la pierre sa première afin que tu
te faisais un gardien noir parce que moi
car j'ai lu mon dos aussi en sortant de
l'école c'était écrit at il une chance
dans le métier non
oui parce que
piller je comprends leur point de vue
ils disaient la vérité dans ce sens je
peux pas jouer intello c'est pour monter
sling alors qu'est ce qui va faire
fait qu'elle aimait l'oeil de théâtre
expérimental commencé
puisque plus important c'était tellement
stade est tel casting de toute façon on
écoutait comme tout la même couleur en
tête ou nude à boîte tout le monde
s'inquiète
jean-pierre ronfort tout nu ça marche ça
passe
pour les quarts mais vous avez type
résilient on vous dit on y fera pas
médecin ouais et voulait percer vous
avez persévéré mais j'ai quand je
continue à faire des enfants justement
expérimental est
un moment d y est arrivé ce qu'on
appelle des profiteurs s'ils viennent à
montréal
ils choisissent un acteur pour jouer la
cage aux folles bien juste moi je
choisisse moins
enfin pour tout dire que 10 fait elle
qui a tout ici
libyen doit en même temps denise
filiatrault a décrit chez denise qui est
un choc c'est 2 millions 3 je compte des
côtes
[Musique]
pire même taille succès de la nm fax qui
a même temps les producteurs de lait ont
eu la brillante idée de dire on va
prendre un métis un but là vous faites
pour annoncer le lit et tout ce qui est
arrivé mais parce que d'aller se crashe
ma meilleure puis avec le les québécois
qui ont beaucoup d'ouverture c'est ce
qu'au début il m'appelait le petit noir
mais encore là ce n'est pas
nécessairement péjorative c'était et
online chinois dans la bras tout est
incertaine et pas vous travaillez comme
un malade je pense que le mont aigoual
juste comment faisiez-vous pour livrer
la marchandise et ne jamais dormir chez
eux j'ai aucune idée
je sais maintenant
qu avec l'usure je pourrai plus jamais
faire sien pendant bonne chose dormait à
côté de la batterie de paul brochu
[Musique]
parce que la pulsation du bes drôme mais
comme dans le ventre de ma mère je
dormais tout le temps partout alors
c'était comme un oiseau qui grignote la
journée ben moi je dormais je grignotais
de sommeil un peu plat journée mais sur
l'île peu bon tournées de nuit comme par
exemple celle hainaut des ponts qui vous
sont offerts à des prix imbattables
battant ivry réno-dépôt
magasins soit fermé alors je dors bh -
dans le coin des tapis rouge met
m'installais ces tapis je dormais il me
réveillait
alors c'était sur tout même avis
quand j'annonçais kreisler le coucher
d'une voiture dans une grosse voiture
mais tu peux nous est classé jeudi fois
je dormais 2a le tank place d'éclaireurs
que j'avais mon deux heures de fête set
mais j'ai fait ce bond à 10 années
derrière la maman brad wall de beau et
chaud de belle et bum quatre jours
d'énergie ans qui joue du banjo ya
quelqu'un qui bon qui a peur de la mort
wen qui croyant mais qui aussi en cube
qui ont été nerveux qu'elle traque un
kir takacs par qui c'est byzance et en
k2 dans ma brown oui il y en a 1
dernière main à qui on a demandé de
jouer au tel
y'a quelqu'un qui est tétanisé un des
deux qui qui qui vont mourir ses rangs
de source indépendante allez vous enfin
je sais pas
je ne sais pas où j'en ai parlé
je sais pas j'en ai parlé à venir
chasser
bichonne ce bout
donc c'est la suite pendant ma peau et
aux hypothèses je pense que si je le
fais une fois
pas gelé déjà fait mais si je le fais de
fouet si ça se passe bien même si je
pense pas bien mais que je prends très
mourir sur scène je veux la faire passer
sur mon adn c'est ce que j'ai appris en
premier afin
je vous dis le mot de cambronne puis je
vous souhaite du théâtre laboratoire
pour la prochaine année
une salle à côté du sage mais coûte que
ça je peux donner une table à face du
symbole